les Gaulois envahissent Bruxelles où
Albert huderzo l'auteur d'Astérix a
lancé son nouvel album une exposition
qui va voyager avant d'atterrir à
l'utesse d'ici quelques années pour
célébrer les 50 ans du village des
irréductibles Marie-Pierre farcass
Pascal
steta ils sont fous ces Belges laisser
quelques irréductibles installer leur
campement sur la Grand Place de
Bruxelles c'est prendre un risque
inconsidéré mais la harp et celtique le
chaudron pas magique et les Gaulois
viennent du Finist
le village est là jusqu'à demain pour
les B et
pour Albert roi d'un jour revient en
Belgique et c'est un
pélerinage c'est un très vieux souvenir
un très bon souvenir très viux souvenir
50 ans
même plus
55 enfin pas tout à fait car c'est en
1951 qu'aludo rencontre René
Anne sa fille est là pour la photo
souvenir
Anne l'exposition raconte aussi cette
amitié vu par de Gaulois l'un petit
grincheux l'autre plus enveloppé ils
sont nés il y a 46 ans et ils ont fait
le tour du monde 310 millions d'albums
vendus du coup la conférence de presse
pour la sortie d' 15 jours de leur
prochain carnet de voyage atti beaucoup
de journalistes et des questions est-ce
que j'ai imaginerait vé non au
référendum de 29 mai est-ce que vous
pouvez préciser si ça aurait été un nom
de gauche ou un nom de droite merci
Astérix ne fait pas de politique hudero
l'a dit et répété il se contente depuis
des années d'égayer les cours de
récré